according to one estimate sending one
kilogram of anything to the moon on a
spacecraft would cost fifteen thousand
dollars a consideration weighing on nasa
as they ramp up the artemis program half
a century after the apollo missions
having a permanent base on the moon will
be important in order to take that next
leap and go into and explore different
locations in space and growing plants
using water and soil we find on the moon
will be crucial for our ability to
sustain longer duration stays there we
will live off the land instead of
constantly having new foods sent up so
when space biologists recently grew
plants in actual moon soil it was a game
changer let's find out how they did it
all plants need light air water a source
of nutrition and optimal temperature but
growing plants is different in space
it's a hostile environment you don't
have an atmosphere you don't have the
elements that help us and plants and
animals thrive no oxygen no co2 and
until some years ago we thought no water
we now know that there is water on the
moon part of the artemis program we'll
see how much water we can mine to grow
plants there are big temperature fluxes
between a lunar day and a lunar night
there could be almost a 300 degree
celsius swing in temperatures there's no
atmosphere and also there's no
protective magnetic shell around the
moon the way we have a protective
magnetic shell around earth called the
van island belt and so what happens is
ionizing particles that are coming from
solar wind or from galactic cosmic
radiation bombard the surface of the
moon they're also micrometeorites that
are bombarding the surface that is what
is called space weathering not to be
confused with the type of weather or
erosion we have on earth we have rivers
and we have wind and these cause erosion
and it will often make those jagged
rocks much more gentle they'll round off
the edges whereas we don't have the
benefit of that kind of erosion on the
surface of the moon this constant
bombardment with cosmic rays and pelting
with space rocks basically makes the
moon soil toxic to plants even though
the composition
of the actual regolith has many of the
same elements that we have on earth rich
in iron and silicon and potassium and
manganese and magnesium but how it
reacts to biological materials can be
different because of these impacts rock
particles can reform into what is called
agglutinates and they can trap in them
some of these metals which can in fact
be harmful to plants it's so different
it's not even called soil it's called
regolith because technically soil has
beneficial organic material like
microbes insects or decaying plants
scientists weren't even sure if moon
soil could sustain plants at all that's
what makes the recent study using actual
moon regolith brought back by astronauts
so groundbreaking this study from the
university of florida tested the growth
of plants in three different soils
collected from apollo 11 12 and 17. a
half century ago astronauts landed on
different parts of the moon where they
collected moon regolith for example
apollo 11 landed and explored a spot
where the dirt was more space weathered
i was trolling
one day the scientists took this moon
soil which was sealed for decades at
johnson space center placed arabidopsis
thaliana seeds in tiny growth wells
filled with less than one gram of apollo
moon soil nutrients and water and waited
two days later they found that all of
these arabidopsis plants were sprouting
with time as the plants grow more and
more the plants are more stunted the
leaves are smaller and there's this
reddish pigmentation and they looked at
the rna profile of these cells by gene
expression they found that those also
showed a signature of stress and so one
yes the plants can grow in the regolith
and two the regolith does cause some
stress in the plant not surprisingly the
plants grown in the older more
space-weathered apollo 11 regolith were
the most stressed so those soils then
caused more toxicity on the plant those
visible signs of stress further study
will be needed to determine why exactly
that's the case or whether introducing
microbes into the soil or growing more
drought resistant plants or plants with
higher nutritional content would work
but one thing astronauts have figured
out is the water and sunlight situation
in space starting from the mere space
station the space shuttle years the
international space station we have
managed to grow plants in space what
you're seeing here is the veggie unit
the advanced plant habitat on the
international space station today i'm
going to show you how we water the
garden here in space watering a plant
which we can do so easily on the surface
of the earth is much more challenging in
space on earth you know you have rain
comes down gravity then makes the water
flow into the ground the international
space station has an environment of
microgravity we have to use a bag
with water in it
and a syringe you don't want to water
too much because you don't want that
water to choke the plants from accessing
the oxygen that it needs for respiration
on the moon you have 1 6 of gravity you
have on earth so that's more gravity
helping you than on the iss but the
sunlight is trickier on the lunar
surface with two weeks of darkness
followed by two weeks of light due to
the moon's rotation we're not getting
those 12 hours of daylight and 12 hours
of night so we have to create that
artificially and we can do that with led
lights which can give you very specific
wavelengths of light and you can mix
them to make white light so it looks
like sunlight
just a three-day trip away the moon is a
small step that will lead to the giant
leap to mars which involves a very long
journey so there are several reasons why
growing our own food in space is key
currently on the international space
station we have a lot of packaged foods
which are very useful but just as you
can imagine in your own pantry no matter
how carefully and how well we preserve
it and package it eventually the
nutritional components degrade if for
some reason you know your supplies
haven't come on time you have a plan b
anyone who's seen the movie the martian
would agree the fertilizer that he uses
in the movie may not be the fertilizer
that we will use while you can use
astronaut poop it may not be the most
controlled fashion nasa prefers powdered
fertilizer that can be reconstituted
with water so what will a permanent moon
habitat with self-sustaining plant food
sources look like years from now there
are some components that i can tell you
that will very likely be a part of these
habitats that will help us do sustained
stays on the surface of the moon and
then in future for mars one of them is
the fact that we're not going to be
growing plants in large farms like we do
on earth we have to have these
controlled environments where we're
going to grow them it's funny to say but
space is limiting in space we have to
make every square inch of space that we
use to grow plants count one point of
reference are the habitats on the south
pole where researchers currently spend
months in bubbles that protect them from
the harsh environment outside what's
interesting is that these folk love
hanging out and spending time in the
greenhouse one cannot underestimate the
value of having that greenery around you
as you venture far away from the surface
of the earth we will use probably a
combination of hydroponics as well as
using lunar regolith once we have
figured out with research how to
mitigate the toxic effects we will live
off the land and utilize the soil-like
material on the surface of the moon to
help us grow plants the way we grow them
on earth
[Music]
this idea of this one small step then
can lead to this giant leap for
humankind my personal hope is that
artemis will be to this and future
generations what apollo was in the 50s
60s and 70s in terms of getting the
younger folk excited about all the tools
the capabilities you know all of the
skills that we're going to need to
thrive in these environments as our next
leap into exploration
[Music]